yeah welcome to this video playing EMP
tell you from France Jacques Brel is
someone really cold breath no name in
them okay so an old Indian Kings Indian
something like that yeah an old Indian
now this is an interesting line they
even zoom in a book on it yeah 95 is the
most ambitious move but i don't really
know it yeah i'll keep it simple just
play play solidly this Queenie 7 it
intends to set up on the soul of Kings
Indian attack just with colors reversed
ok you can argue the Kings Indian attack
with colored reverse isn't this just the
Kings Indian yeah it is but it's some
storm more common to see the set up with
colors reversed yeah what I'm trying to
do is quite simply not castling I have
many many moves to play on the queenside
ok so he's trying to fight for her space
let's just take it
yeah probably takes with the pawn and
see if I yet again okay but now I have
some lines open on the on the queenside
so maybe i can i can just safely castle
he will still try to get in the tech
going but I have something open on the
queenside okay Bishop e3 yeah probably
he still my place c5 but no he doesn't
okay night h7 g5 and then trying to
sacrifice I will prepare this year with
the should have one so I have aged three
covered alright so should I push pause
here a five Queenie for now maybe at the
moment I'm just looking at the d6 bond
which is nice but not not decisive or
anything okay oh no a six and A six is
much better attending would be seven
okay so Queen a phone now of course i
always need to think about possible
sacrifices here this King age to a moose
or is it too slow
well they will probably SEC them
yeah okay let's protect this if he wants
to break through we will need to sack a
quite quite a bit of material
yup his mess attack is based on pieces
only so on a piece equis probably the
way to go at some point film okay yeah
well see 5 is not a move on I really
fear should I exchange rooks I don't
know but I don't want to invest much
more time this is probably not the best
possible way to play but thinking ages
here doesn't seem appropriate to me
those p sacrifices are very really very
unlikely to work and maybe I I defend
badly okay but it's not objectively
working check
yeah not oh wow this is nice my dad and
now Queen are all the way to to be seven
on not checking at queen bee seven
etching is not bad queen is nicely
positioned on before Queen B seven yeah
you can take and play 97 but I can i can
activate pieces now in this position is
just good for white as yeah try a letter
checking is over and now why does just
better on the queenside okay let's bring
this into plate 95 as a possible way to
go there was also the capture a 95 this
would have been strong already in 96
okay what the serve is still possible
yeah even the simple led c5 is not bed
hmm yeah I don't know they're all good
they all good even taking taking here's
good okay but let's let's open up the
position this is probably the best way I
mean this King is it isn't secure I
didn't even consider this but maybe it's
not so bad
Queen f8 would be a very nice big check
that if you know I to be seven it's also
a good idea my king is so secure not
much happening down you cannot really
move anything here we cannot move the
bishop and you cannot lose the night I'm
just toying with 96 check i know i have
a Bishop b5 check no this is nice no and
he hmm
time warning job this is probably
completely winning but I don't see how
check check Oh check this this is this
is winning check check check check check
check yeah I manage checkmate yeah but
if it doesn't plunder the Queen I prom
DM have a big-time problem I mean the
position as a seller for black am pretty
sure it's a fuss made even I don't
really see how our queen d6 meet ya
Queen d6 mid and if he goes him and this
Queen D 6 of 6 mid yeah it's a first
mate already Quincy 7 is actually the
best move still leading to a mate yeah
the problem is and this is typical for
this kind of attacks of you base your
tech on piece play only and basically
his old game was geared towards
sacrificing on age 3 here this is the
exactly the the only idea that black has
and sometimes it's working but here if
it doesn't work um black will be in bad
shape on the queenside here Ruby salmon
was good okay I didn't didn't see that I
protected all this just exchange stuff
him and this was probably not the most
forceful way to play but it should
retain some edge this advanced pawn is
something to play for in those pawns so
we
yeah I think this was really really a
bad this yang this d5 and the exchange
and now this position is really one
sided my pieces are all working on the
queenside where these a bit a bit off
ciety you will never ever be able to
second age three and now i'm just still
clearly better just a matter of from
realizing the the edge yeah and widest
it was really winning here according to
the comp I probably didn't play here
played when he moves okay this was one
of them here he I could have just taken
actually yeah this is this is very easy
but sometimes you you think to
complicate it and this is mrs. checkmate
very easy and this is check also get
quite quite good winning the house yeah
but this is very very typical if you
don't break through here then you get
get problems on on the queenside thanks
for watching